strangely up to this tournament up to  the match  i think magnus played the martial both  in stavanger and he played it in the  world cup not as his main opening in all  the time but quite often and uh  well it becomes this kind of strange  double bluff that if you save everything  for the match then becomes more  predictable so you try to mix it in some  way and uh  i don't know but this this of course  became a cornerstone of our preparation  um strangely enough this was also  the more or less openly opening he  played with black against kayaking so it  could look like we think it's a  speciality against russian players but  it's pretty good opening  chesable.com for example  great expert in martial in the team so  this was quite